and i saw khabib fight his last fight right
and something really caught my attention like
he's a main character and he plays a big
role in in the film in the sinaloa cartel
they do a lot of witchcraft craft with new
mexico they deal with a lot of gin over there
in in mexico and for me that was like just like
go like like stories to scare kids right i felt
this gin grab my ham brother like he grabbed he
his his fingers were so long that he went like
masha'allah allah
now our next guest was living in a very dark
world in a very dark place in life the only thing
he believed in was death as he had encountered
so much of it he was a high-ranking member of
one of the main carnatell organizations in mexico
gunfights with government agents and other cartels
until he thought of actually killing himself
because he had touched the rock bottom in life
so we want to find out with our next guest how
islam and the quran impacted his life so much so
that he's actually on the dean's show with my next
guest go ahead and subscribe right now hit that
notification bell help us get our numbers back
up did you know that many years ago the dean show
when we started 2006 we used to broadcast for many
years on the khalifa clothing channel currently
known as digital minbot so we're trying to get
our numbers back up because the channel at that
time got closed then we started the official d
show channel we're trying to get our numbers back
up to where they should be and that's this number
here 855 combined what we currently have 442
we should be over a million 200 000 subscribers
help us to get our numbers back to where they
should be with that small setback that we had
many years ago you guys can help us by subscribing
right now and hitting that notification bell
thank you very much enjoy the rest of this
show salaam and don't forget to support us
on our patreon page hello american brother
how are you doing my brother i'm doing pretty
good how are you i'm good hamdulillah so
so you were you're you were
actually a high-ranking member
in the cartel yeah um i i i belonged to
several cartels um before i went to jail
i worked for a first for a small cartel um down
in mexico city i ended up going to jail and then i
i ended up going back to the cartels working
for a bigger organization because of um
what i did inside of jail you know what i
had uh the reputation i had earned inside
of uh prison but it's it was really difficult you
know it's been um it's been a really long journey
so for people that don't know what the
cartel is we're going to go ahead and share
with them a short little video here so they can
kind of get an idea the kind of lifestyle you were
this year on record despite hopes that the covet
19 crisis would slow down violent crime it's had
the opposite effect more than 17 000 people were
murdered in the first half of this year alone
in kuliakan a city of about 800 000 in the
headquarters of the notorious and lower cartel
no one is off limits for ernesto martinez it's
the brutality of the killings that stand out
jesus manuel was a 42 year
old local police officer
a few days before he turned up dead he'd been
kidnapped by cartel members that's his brain hey
oh man really why would they have done this like
what what was he involved with them in some way
an element so i'm sure people get the point now
you know so how do you go from you're born in
mexico raised came at an early age to california
and now how do you end up in such a organization
um you know they i was i was taken to uh to
california when i was like a year i don't have
i don't have memories of mexico i grew up
in california i went to school in california
you know the the type of lifestyle that's
here in california knows a lot of gangs
you grew up with a lot of racism um and it
was like my my family my family actually was
my family's christian right um i grew up in in
the christian church going to a baptist church
but something happened when i was really young
um my family got torn apart my father ended up uh
in in state prison and it was it's actually
something really really uh really personal
in my in in our life what what he did to our
our family he broke our family apart right
and it was like i would i would uh i was
really young when that happened uh the
last time i saw him i think i was 10. um
and i haven't seen him since you know but
i was really mad at the time because like i would
say to myself like out i would see my mom that
my mom was going to church and she would always
take us to church and and i and i would say like
why did why did this happen to us if if my
mom was looking for for god you know um i
was too young to to actually like really
believe in god but i i would never like
i would never see that like i would see
christianity sometimes you know like
wondering like why why would
you guys worship a human being
what was so special of him
to be crucified to be killed
i when i was younger when i when i was younger i
was really like i was i was um grown to be like i
i grew up being proud of who i was being proud of
i was met because i was mexican you know that it
was it was all about that that brown and proud of
that mexican pride that like always came up like
like that's the type of person i i was um when
when my family was broken apart like i started
doing things i shouldn't do you know hanging
around with the wrong people i i ended up um you
know like like any normal kid you know stealing
just like i would sometimes like try to like
do do stuff just like try to help my mom because
i would i would i would see my mom at like at 9 10
12 at night crying you know because she had uh she
was left alone with four kids i was the oldest one
and she had never worked in the us she
didn't speak english she spoke only spanish
and i really like i was i was too
young no to to see what had happened
what my father had done in my family uh the
way that he had destroyed my family you know
um i started just like looking for an excuse to to
to belong to to gangs you know to to start doing
criminal criminal activity basically my mom
told me like hey um if you're gonna follow that
life like stay away from your brothers because
you're going to give them a bad example right
and i was like i would always try to like
blame that what had happened with my father um
in in our family and like i would always try
to blame that like oh i'm i'm gonna i'm i'm
i'm following the way i'm i'm going because
uh because of what he did to our family
but i was just looking for an excuse right um i
started getting into trouble and i and i was like
i had to leave the i had i had to leave the u.s
and i had to just try to like look for something
different because of the problems that i was uh
i was getting into but i didn't know that it's
it's very difficult in mexico and it's even even
more crazier i i had no idea to to what extent i
was going to get involved right you had no no
idea what was waiting for you exactly like i
i thought that that was bad like that they were
like they were bad like they were they were real
gangsters i had no idea of what the human being is
capable of doing you know i came down to mexico um
life is really hard right because it's
like it's it's a third world country
uh this there's not a lot of money um i went
to the south part of mexico it's a there's a
there's a small state called uh guerrero
um i was there for a couple of months
i didn't like it and i moved to to a
state that's close to mexico city but
i still felt like i i felt i felt alone because
i didn't i didn't know anybody right um i met a
person that i consider my brother because like
um he saw that he saw what i was going through
it's been a long time you know since i've seen
my mom when i left them i was really young when
i started walking by myself when i started
trying to like live by myself so it gets like
it for me like christmas new year were really
bad days like because i would see like all
the families get together right and and i would
remember what happened to my family how my dad had
affected our family and a lot of people like they
they would probably want to know i don't want to
share what happened to my family because i i don't
want to like um it was something difficult you
know i just don't want to i i don't want to say it
but it was something that that was really personal
that i think that if if i would have been like if
if that would have happened if my dad would have
done what he did when i was a little bit older
i would have probably took in his life you know
at the time i couldn't because i was too young
you know i was too scared and and and what he
what he had done what he had done affected us
really hard um so when i came down here i i met
this this person that i really he really cared
for me his name his name was martin he had uh
we called them his nickname was ninote you know he
he was from border brothers from uh from san diego
he was living in the south and and he when when
i met him he's like hey i'm gonna show you some
homie love you know and uh he gave me some stuff
and he's like whenever you want to kick it you
come down here so i started kicking it with
him you know he was so he was a small store for
for uh for for a criminal
organizing organization right
but he started showing me loyalty and he
started showing me that that i wasn't alone um
i had already done a couple of things
you know i hadn't been that involved
in in in the type of life that that that requires
you to be in the organization so i like a lot of
people ask me like why did you join like did
you join because of you you needed money you
needed power i didn't the the government's so
corrupt down here and like society's so corrupt
like um they killed they killed him in front
of his kids right they they gunned them down
in front of his kids um this friend of yours
yeah this friend of mine and they when when that
happened you know like i went to his funeral and i
noticed that you know you don't have friends like
before he got killed like a lot of a lot of like
almost all like in in that barrio in that mario
a lot of a lot of the friends he would have
a lot of friends when he was alive because he
he would sell drugs right he he sold we like
there's because there's different type of drugs
but um i would see that they were like everybody
was his friend while he was alive but when he got
killed i consider him a friend because i was very
loyal to him because he showed me he he showed me
a lot of capitalism you know a lot of brotherhood
when when he killed when he got killed um
i was like well i was the only one me and me and
a 13 year old kid that would that he uh to this
day he he tells me like you guys were like you're
like you guys were like my big brothers you know
because we would we would like tell them hey
what are you doing like don't hang around with
those people because they're they're
smoking crystal they're doing cocaine
you know we were always trying to like keep them
away like hey stay in school you know like uh
try to take care of them because we knew where
we were at and we knew where we were heading
when this happened like i had a
lot of like i had i had a lot of uh
anger in my heart i i wanted to
get revenge for what happened right
so i got in i got in contact with the people that
he was working for and and they were like do you
have experience like what have you done and like
i told them well i have experience i'm not scared
but alright then let's go they took me they gave
me they gave me equipment they gave me people and
and i started working you know i started working
but with with that mentality that i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get those persons i'm gonna get those
people back i'm gonna get those people back
when when i was i i wasn't able to bury him
because those same people that that killed
him they were trying to they were looking for me
as well um and it really hurt me you know to see
that that none of the none of those those those
persons that would say that they were your friends
they don't they're not there when when you die
you know though those are just fake friends
that that the world gives you and when i started
getting involved in this you know i started like
growing because i was not afraid you know
i've always been like that type of i've
always had that type of warrior mentality
i found my damn imma die fighting you know
and i i did i did start getting those
people that had done that to my brother
but i ended up in a situation where i got caught
up you know i got caught up with uh with weapons
and with some drugs you know i got caught up
i got i got caught by the uh by the mexican
government so they they they they catch me
and and um they give they torture me right
they're like hey you're not because i had already
been i had already been uh once caught because
i got caught with the with the nine millimeter
because we were going to go do do a a business
but the the government caught us but i went to
i went into uh to the holding cells and like
the cartel got me out real quick the second time
they got me they're like you're not gonna leave
them but i like i know the laws here so i was
like nah like like i'm just gonna pay the i'm
gonna pay the the fine for the for the for the
weapons i'm gonna sign for the drug and i'm gone
um i didn't i wasn't expecting that that that
the mexican government was going to change
change things around and they were
going to put me a murder case you know
because they knew i was working
for that organization they knew
i didn't say anything about the organization
because i know how things are here you know
when you say something when you rat someone out
you you get dealt with and sometimes by the same
by the same government the government like he's
they're just testing you if you say if you talk
about if you talk about the the mafia or if you
talk about the cartel they won't report you they
that you got they they you uh they they have you
they'll take you and they'll they'll give you up
so you got to see a lot of different scary things
how you talk about this being just a really dark
world i can't imagine when when this happened
like when they put me when they got when i was uh
that murder when i got that murder case um i went
into prison right and i would see a lot of like
um i wasn't a believer like i i didn't believe
like even if i had i had that christianity like
i had been in uh as a kid i had been uh i grew
up in christianity i didn't really believed in it
i i started saying a lot of weird
things you know like down here in mexico
there's no what they believe in a lot of a lot of
people believe in the holy death right have you
heard of that have you heard of her yeah let me
uh actually i was that's what i'm going to ask you
there's a couple couple video clips here
i wanted to uh ask your question on this
are you familiar with this yeah
for the audience tell us and the reason i played
this clip because i i wanted you you talked about
there's a lot of different weird things and a
lot of different things they worship but this
talisman actually around his neck uh is that
familiar is this yeah yeah yeah they're they're
amulets you know you you get them from from
from high from high ranking witches or or uh
how do you say how do you how do you call them um
talismans yeah they like they basically they they
they kill someone and like they'll
they'll offer them to a specific uh
deity or whatever they believe in wow and and
that will protect you um so give our audience this
person now that the authorities are catching he
kind of like hell broke loose man they don't like
the government has let organizations grow so big
like he's a main character and he plays a big role
in in the film in the sinaloa cartel when when
they when they caught him and they caught him
by accident like they weren't trying to get
him like hell broke loose in in in kuliakan
like 100 to 500 trucks came down from the
from the ceiling the from the sinaloa uh
sierra the mountain ranges they came specifically
to to free him or they were going to start a war
and it got crazy man it got really crazy but it
just it's just a small demonstration and this is
um this is a main city of mexico and they had this
much impact now this is what you see in the city
like where we were at and and where we had where
i have been like i've seen to thousands of trucks
like up to 10 000 strong cartels like my cartel
is is one of the it's it's a one it's like um
they have a they they have a pact with with
this cartel right with the sinaloa cartel
because the cinema cartel works from from the
half of of mexico from work where sinaloa is up to
north they they control that part and we're down
in the south uh hitting with the border so there's
a lot of alliances between cartels right and and
there is a lot of like there's a lot of wars also
all right so is this what you were talking
about yeah that's what i'm talking about
so before before i joined the the uh before
i fell into prison like i had already seen
a couple of people with with the holy death you
know i i've never been like a believer in in that
i was very supe superstitious of anything that
was paranormal right or none of those things so
so you have these uh these superstitions that
people believe that's what we and then you have
so many cases of shirk now you obviously know as
you're a new muslim but you know what obviously
the difference between uh the pure monolithism
the tahit versus so you see a ton of happening
tell us uh we're almost out of time what happened
now how did islam how did you in the depths of
all this darkness get exposure you talk about
you heard the quran and it brought you to tears
um basically when i when i left prison i i left
with with a lot of experience right because i i
we had a couple of situations going inside and
i started believing in the holy desk because
like i would see that a lot of people that would
help me out were believers in in this in in her
when i came out i joined i i joined
a very a very large organization
and i spent a lot of time um doing things i
wasn't supposed to i started growing in there
but at the same time i started seeing that people
that like you're just a pawn in the in a big in a
bigger in a better game when when you don't when
when you're not when you're long when you're uh
no longer required you're gonna get cut off
by the same people and maybe like now maybe
uh it's not even like it's not even from the top
someone else that that that wants what you have
he's gonna do he's gonna do something to to
take that away i had it run into a lot of hard
situations where we had encountered government
and we we we've we had to really fight our way out
and like my mentality was was in in
in that i knew i was gonna die there i
knew that my life was gonna end fighting
and and and belonging to these cartels
and that mentality of knowing that i was gonna
die like i wasn't afraid of it you know i was
ready to die and we had we i have i've been
really close to death a lot a lot of times
but what actually started scaring
me was that i wasn't scared of dying
but what was there to come after death
like i started noticing a lot of things
i um a lot allah sent me a dream before i
left that before i left the organization and
i saw myself getting killed by by my own people
right by the whole people that i was working for
i didn't know about god i really didn't
believe in it but i just said like
out of nowhere like i just had to leave you know
i just i had that necessity in my heart just to
leave like just what are you doing like you're
gonna you're gonna die for something that has no
has no no value you're gonna die for people
that are that that are not loyal to you
so i decided to leave like out of nowhere just got
up left in the morning like when they woke up they
were looking for me like crazy because i had a lot
of people that were working for me and i had a con
control over some large territory of that
cartel i just left i ended up in a small city
renting a a a small room um had nothing just by
myself you know and i really didn't know what
was like the what was the purpose of my life
i didn't know why i was still alive when i was
when i had to be dead right and i started getting
i started fighting into depression because of what
i had and what i did to what i was where i was at
and i had that little voice like you're a coward
like you're a coward i thought you were gonna
i thought you were gonna die for those people
okay i thought you were gonna die in the fight
you know that's that's like i felt really lost
like really really last man and i started getting
scared because like of the whispers i would hear
like i couldn't find peace like i i i couldn't
find something you know and got to the point where
i sat down at my bed and i was thinking of like
should i kill myself man like like i'm not i have
not done anything beneficial for no one here in
this life like why you actually got to a point
where you're contemplating suicide huh yeah at
all definitely brother that it got really scary
and that's that's where the moment where i ain't
even like i just closed my eyes and i i i said
like i don't know if you really exist or if you're
hearing me this but like god is merciful brother
and it's hard
because like i don't know how
you know like
i look at my life and and i
guess like god is most merciful
i just asked him like i didn't even know how to
call on him you know because
i had never looked towards him
and i knew that i had never i hadn't done i hadn't
been a i ain't i hadn't been a good person man
and i just asked them like let me know that
you're that you're real let me know guide me
to something that is real because i i'm gonna
lose myself you know i'm gonna lose myself here
where i am the next day i'm
into boxing right i do muay thai
i'm into sports you know i've always
liked to kept myself really healthy
and and i saw khabib fight his last fight right
and something really caught my attention when
when at the end of his fight he would
always give glory to god you know
and i started like looking up because
the only the only thought the only
thing i knew about islam was that like what
what the west showed you what what they
what they try to show teach you about it
like that they're a bunch of terrorists
when i started hearing the rest of
like uh recitations of the holy quran
like my heart was looking for something
was looking for something real man when i heard
it it would break it would break me and until this
day man like i'm thinking of writing a book of
whatever because it's like my story is very long
and and that point was the point that it was
like i had to know more i had to know more
and and it's true what the quran says
only only god guides who he wills
so you are asking that you are a living
testimony that if someone is sincere
and they can be in the cartel they can be in
the mafia they could be in the darkest place
in the darkest room on the darkest night
the darkest hole wherever they are in life
but if they do what you did sincerely
asking the creator the heavens and the earth
you didn't know how to call upon him you
just asked for the guidance you said guide me
exactly got it you didn't you didn't pray to
a saint you didn't pray to a human being to an
angel to jesus to anybody but the one who jesus
prayed to the one who the messengers prayed to
the one who we are called to pray to the one
who created creation the one and only creator
of the heavens and earth god almighty allah so
you prayed to the creator directly and alone and
you asked for guidance you didn't call him at that
time you didn't say allah no what did you say you
were just in spanish or what was in english i i i
just closed my eyes because i was i was getting to
the point where i was looking where to hang myself
from right in prison i learned how a lot of people
a lot of people in prison a lot of some of my
friends they hanged themselves because they had
so you were looking you were looking left right
where to hang yourself and at that time you're
now asking this is your last it was just it was
like am i breaking my breaking point you know
because like i was mad i was mad towards myself
because i like there was a part of me that was
saying like you're a coward man like you're
ready to die like why did you leave like why
did you leave everything behind shaytan is
coming now shaitaan is starting to oh and
it got worse man it got worse like i had never
had experience with with jin until i actually
came until i actually was striving to to
to follow uh the teachings of islam and and
instead of getting like instead
of being scared it even it even um
affirmative like it made stronger my belief in
what i was what i was looking for you know because
at that point like i i always take care of
myself right i'm always taking care of myself
legally because i i don't
want to get caught back up
i said i'm not going back to prison and i'll
die i'd rather fight with government then go
back to britain because of one of the the
experiences that i learned in in in prison
now that i turn around and i look at my life and
and i see that god has guided me to a different
to a different place everything falls and
everything falls in everything falls into perfect
into a into a perfect plan he is the most
he's the most great and he had the perfect
plan because a lot of people like a lot of
my friends that i still talk to they ask me
like they don't they don't believe that
like what are you talking about man
you're you're you're the devil because what
we what we what we've done is cartel members
there's no forgiveness you know that
i would i before it before i became
a muslim i would say like i have no
forgiveness what i've done subhanallah i i have
i knew i was going to die a the way i was going
to die because of the things that had i have done
you know and when i and when i got when i was
in that point the breaking point where i was
already looking for like where to hang myself um
and it and it it it was scary man because like
i didn't find like i couldn't find a purpose like
what made like you were so scared of dying when
you were ready at that when you had encountered
so many so many problems and and so many very
dangerous uh situations like i had bullets flying
like i had like the cars that we were driving
like they would get shot up by the army by by
government and nothing happened to me and a lot of
people were telling me like because uh because i
i like i started believing in in in in this in in
this saint and i would and i would carry i would
carry a talisman as well you know like protection
and one of the friend one of my friends
told me like you know you know that she
only takes care of you for a certain time and
then and then your time your time's up you know
and i told them like we're not afraid of
dying bro like this is what this is who we are
to the extent that the devil shaitan misleads
people to that to that extent and because i didn't
know any i didn't know better you know and now and
now i know that it wasn't her that was taking care
of me it was it was allah god almighty the creator
it's it's really like it's it's really it's really
difficult to swallow that pill you know that he is
over everything else and nothing happens because
nothing happens until he says it you know
and i and i knew like they were everybody
would tell me like even when i was in prison
i had no family i had nobody to that that
would take care of me and every time there was
someone there that that was taking care of me
i found out that they were like they were doing
witchcraft on me right with with this with this
particular thing and um that they were working
me with um with uh with they they call it um
um what is it they go to a certain um cemetery and
and they work they work you so you can so you can
die so so they make they they
do a lot of witchcraft craft
new mexico they deal with a lot of gin over there
in in mexico but i i wasn't a believer you know i
had not like even even though like i had it i had
her there i was like man but now now that you know
uh from studying islam you know that this is
what they were dealing with making connections
with jinns yes they were making this world of the
evil spirits but you know what like and now i know
like be like the person that was that was doing
this to me he thought that that that those people
were gonna that those that they were gonna affect
me but god used these people to take care of me
all all my time in prison the same people
that would come up would be believers would
be believers in in in this in in this in
this uh thing and then instead of costing
me harm they would benefit me and benefit
me in the form that like they're they were
like they in prison you find out who are your real
friends because you can't give them anything and
and instead of them like looking down on me they
would help me out and they would tell me like
you're you're going to be someone man you're
different they would always tell me that like
you're different you have different you you have
a different mentality you're you're a very smart
person and now without and like i would always
say i'm not here to stay you know even though i
knew i had murder i had murder and i was facing up
to 20 to 35 years in prison i i was going to spend
the rest of my life there i was not scared you
know i would tell them like i'm not here to stay
man i'm here to grow i'm here to learn and i'm
going to come out even stronger not knowing that
not knowing that i was going to find guidance
to to what i now know no but tell us go ahead
when i came out and and i was and i was doing that
uh a certain friend that was really involved in in
witchcraft and and and and all this he told me
he's like hey there's this there's this uh witch
that wants to do a cleaning on you because
he's saying that you have that they're that
they're working you and i was like nah i'm good
man he's like he says that you're gonna end up
you're gonna end up very in a very bad position
any and he's like and they're working you with
you with that same saint that you have on
your on on because i had a talisman right
he's like they're working with you with their
they're doing something to you and not knowing
not knowing what what like what they were doing
like i didn't really pay attention to it but
allah allah was protecting me from everything that
they were doing because nothing that they would do
would actually get to me when and when
i left everything when i started when i
when i when i left everything behind i even
like the day the day that i decided to leave
i i ripped it off my my neck and i threw it i
threw it and and i and i said to myself like
what am i doing like i didn't even believe in
this and i'm falling into this because i would
see things going on in my life when i decided
to to accept islam and i was doing my prayers
it was difficult because i don't have
anywhere to go you know to this day i
don't have anywhere to to go to like try to
get knowledge the only knowledge that i have
is by reading the quran and and what allah
gives me to understand you know and and
and seeing your videos man i'm a big fan of
yours i always see your videos and and they
they really motivate me you know i had the
the i i woke up for five year prayer right
i went i went back to bed and i started looking
at how how shaytan became and his purpose
brother like not a minute passed when i
felt like something get on top of me right
i couldn't move like i tried to i tried to
talk and i i felt like like my lips were sealed
i had never had any type of encounter with jinns
like dad like i for me that was like just
like go like like stories to scare kids right
i felt this gin grab my ham brother like
he grabbed he his his fingers were so long
that he went like this and he wrapped he wrapped
his hand like on mine and and i and i was fighting
like i was laying down without like not being
able to move and and i even tried to move my hand
and i like he grabbed like he grabbed the hold
of my twice i felt his fingers go like this he
picked me up out of my bed and turned my head
like head bottom and he dragged me in the middle
of the room i was scared that he was gonna let me
go and i was gonna like i was gonna break my neck
the only thing i could say like
the only thing that i would that
i i remember was this is what i like i
i murmured it because i couldn't speak
but i said a lot but and like
this brother what did you say
you praised allah just by like murmuring like i
felt back in my bed and like the gin left right
you felt the grip let go just by like just by
trying to say because i couldn't speak but just by
making the intention of glorifying
god like this gin dropped me boom
back on my bed i woke up and my heart was like
i had never i had never encountered that right
here in mexico they have like they have a like
a lot of people say that they see demons and
they see james and my neighbor that i didn't even
like talk to because i'm i'm a very like i don't i
don't have friends man i keep everything to myself
i don't go out like he knocked on my door and he's
like hey can i can i tell you something i
was like yeah what's up man he's like um
there was i want to tell you something but don't
get scared i was like yeah he did he doesn't know
who i am right he's like there was there was three
there was three things there was three people
standing outside your house yesterday i'm like
what do you mean he's like um they weren't people
he's like they were deemed like demons
right that's like they were they were gin
that there were three dog talk three dark
tall jeans outside my outside of my house
and and i told them like oh yeah i know man
don't worry we left and i went back into my
my room and i i just said alhamdulillah god is
good because the devil the devil did not does
not want to did not want to let me go he was
mad you know that's how you you you connected
because the previous lifestyle and all of
the horrible things you did from the past
you were a good worker for him huh exactly
and and and he wanted like he wanted
he knew he knew because like there's a lot
of things that have happened in my life that
i couldn't find explanation to right a lot of
things happened in my life and and i've had a
lot of things happen that i would like i would say
to myself man maybe you're crazy like why are you
having these why you having why are you seeing
these things when i didn't believe in them and
when when i started like looking for for
a lot i started like concentrating on i
started saying i'm gonna change my life i'm gonna
be something better if i was willing to die for
for for for those for those wrong reasons now
i'm going to do that for all the right reasons
brother i had got this job right the
second day i became a muslim they fired me
like everything started going
against me like everything
and instead of instead of me getting
mad you know i i asked myself like
this is a test to know if you're if you really
want to change or at the first at the at the first
at the first encounter of problems you're going
to run back to what you know what what you used
to know because that was all i know i knew to do
what i used to do before i i don't really want to
say what i did because it's like glorifying
that but i was a very evil person you know
i would take care of business without feeling any
type of without having a heart and when when i
started looking for god like i started seeing how
i lost my job like everything was going downhill
brother like people would call me up like
hey we know you we know you left but we want
to we want you to take care of business
we're going to pay you this much money
like the money that they were offering
was 50 grand to take care of business
like offers were coming and coming for me to to
to run back anybody would like anybody would run
back to that right if i was if i didn't know
what i had encounter and i did if i didn't
know what what what a lot had guided me to i would
have done it because i had that was my life that
was stuff that was what i used to do that was my
business but i knew that inside of me i would say
are you gonna turn your back on your creator now
that he has guided me to something that is true
i that is true i am 100 sure this is this
is the true religion because like i talked
to muslims and they asked me how did you
know about how did you find out about islam
did someone preach to you did
someone share dawah with you
may allah continue to bless you my brother we want
to get you on these last couple of minutes we have
we want to connect you how can people now for the
spanish community you know to go ahead you talked
about you don't really have a community there and
now you want to continue to learn you want to grow
there's one new muslim academy academy online
that we recommend is for new muslims right after
they take shahadah it's a course now but then
also bigger than that we want to connect you we
want to go ahead and you know get you with the
right people there's our brothers from islamic
spanish.com have you heard of this website islam
islaminspanish.com have you heard of that uh i
think i have yeah uh but how could some of these
uh brothers you know our hispanic latino brothers
you know connect with you you you're currently
uh are you in california you're in mexico i'm
still in mexico i'm close to the border yeah um i
don't really want to say where i'm at because yeah
that's why you're that's why you were wearing
the glasses and the hat yeah a lot of people
want to see want to me me in a very bad
place because yeah i can imagine so uh if um
well we'll have them reach out to would you they
they can reach out to you yeah and and and um
you can you can your email i'll give you your
yeah you have my information you know okay and
basically i was that's why i try to reach out to
you man like because here like i i sometimes like
i'm striving you know and and like i'm not going
to give up i'm not going to give up now that i
i know what is what is real because i've seen
it firsthand in my life you know and when i
started learning about the the companions
of of prophet muhammad peace be upon him
like i would get goosebumps you know because i was
like man i'm a warrior like i would have loved to
been i would love to be in there you know knowing
that i was gonna die for the right cause because
like that's what that's what i would always like
that was that was my main goal you know like
i'm i'm a warrior but now i know that before
before being a warrior i'm a slave of allah
you know and i just i ask him for guidance every
day and and like i have i've been going through
some some tough the most the most important
thing that we can that we can have and that
they can never take away from us we can lose
everything we can lose freedom we can lose
everything we can lose in this world this
this world but the the guidance that he gives
is something that we really have to
appreciate because not everybody is
guided not everybody has the knowledge that we
have and the knowledge that we have been given
and it's really true i really hold
that dear that he guides who he will
you know and and that's why we see so much
people going astray and so much people falling in
in in in that because they are they're still not
guided but if you do if you do have guidance and
you do believe in it don't ever let it go because
that is that is the most that's the most greatest
thing we can have the guidance of them all the
of the creators of the heavens and the earth
absolutely and they can never take that
away you know we can lose everything
i've lost everything and the only thing i have is
him and that's the only thing i did you know so
i'm i'm happy i'm happy i'm really love everything
i know everything's gonna everything is is i'm
getting to that point and i i really want to learn
more because like i talk to my friends you know i
have a lot of friends still in that business and
like they tell me like hey we respect you man
we know we didn't like we're not you're not the
type of person that just like turns you back
like that he's been into gunfights with you like
we've been in gunfights with you you're not you
ain't no coward but you know and now i understand
that i have there's a great there's a great plan
i want to be able to tell those people that
are in in the mafia they're in the cartels
because a lot of people like they they think
they don't have heart we have a lot of heart
and i know that a lot of them are there because
they have they can have their own reasons
but i want to share this message because here
in mexico there's basically no muslims you know
there's very very few inshallah we can get
this uh you can get this message to them
uh and share it with them so we'll try to
inshaallah connect you now we'll many people
will see this episode and inshallah they reach
out to us and we'll try to make some connections
uh and then shall i go from there and i appreciate
man um you giving me the opportunity to share
because i really didn't want to like i was
thinking of it like yesterday i was just reaching
out so like so you can give me some advice i
didn't really want to come on the show and like
i'm i wasn't that i was like what am i doing
but very very very inspirational story uh
live testimony to again someone who can be in the
darkest of places in the world but so many gems
from your story and one of the greatest is to call
on the crater alone without any talisman without
any [ __ ] without any saints but just the one god
the creator of the heavens and earth and ask for
guidance like you did and when you were looking
around left and right where you're going to hang
yourself you were asking right before that for the
guidance and you got guided that's why you're here
with us on the dean's show turned to
the created heavens and earth in islam
and i've been eight months eight months striving
to become a better muslim keep moving forward
keep pressing forward young brother check out this
this uh this website new muslimacademy.com it's a
really good website and we'll try to make those
other connections inshallah we'll send you the
okay nice it was nice meeting you and
like i hope you're blessed brother you
too brother opportunity you're welcome
salaam laker formally brother thank you
wow can you imagine being in that position now
that you go from california to mexico and now
you're in the cartel and you're just doing
you can't imagine he didn't want to go into
the details of any of the horrific things that he
did but then he just hightailed it out of there
and then he's like hey he's about to i mean the
just the darkness you know has overtaken the heart
and the soul and he's about to commit suicide he's
looking around from the left to the right where to
hang himself and he does look he don't know about
islam the only thing he heard about islam he's
thinking these guys are terrorists and now but
he's doing something that's innate in the human
being he's calling upon the creator of the heavens
and earth alone he's calling upon the creator he's
saying look guide me he didn't call upon it he'd
say jesus he didn't say god he didn't say allah he
just said guide me he but he was calling sincerely
to the one create to the creator that's what
the main takeaway you can be in the worst place
in your life you're not living with purpose
but now you are sincerely wanting to know
your purpose in life you want to know
where you're going when you die why you're
here ask the creator of the heavens and
earth ask from the depths of your heart and
soul sincerely guide me guide me guide me
and you'll be surprised what happened
look what happened to our brother
our brother there this amazing story and look
at the perseverance i'll make dua for him so
he can remain steadfast thank you for tuning in
to the show subscribe if you haven't already go
ahead and feel free to share all of our episodes
out there with the world because through these
stories we're changing lives we're inspiring
people so they can go ahead and find their
purpose live their purpose inshallah god one
thank you peace be with you assalamu alaikum